Ray apps is on camera yelling at people
to go into the capital he's on camera
and then he's on the front line the
Trump thing as the bearings are torn
down
well I don't know he was ramming cops he
was holding a barrier that eventually
ended up ramming cops a huge Trump sign
that they picked up sideways
officers but that means I can tell you
that the dude told people to go in the
building and that is on the front line
when they breached the capitol grounds
that's enough well and then I remember
seeing him multiple times throughout the
day on the initial breach you know in
the secondary breach I mean right as
everything really hit the fan that's
when he backed off he just backed off
and kind of faded away into the crowd
and just watched it all take place so I
don't know a clear investigation proves
that he's a Fed a lot of people think he
is but I do think it's absolutely
fascinating that the lawyer is trying to
say that Joe Rogan in any way instigated
January 6 when Rogan's never even had
Trump on his pocket and he refuses to
have Trump on his podcast from what I'm
aware of I don't know I don't know I
don't know if that's I think that's the
media exaggerating